あれ、今日のTwitter
あの、俺、もう決めたからマジでやばいから
あの、動画の最初にtwitter絶対一人かえすから待ってろ
動画の中で
覚えてればね
まじ、目についた人にすぐ返すからね
もう、さらすからな
悪口言った人はそのままさらすから
バイト行ってきますー
行ってらっしゃい
ハイというわけでやばいです
すごい　あの～
正直言いましょう
どうでもいい動画っちゃぁ　どうでもいい
俺にとっちゃぁどうでもいい　けど、
ひょっとしたら
あの～やばいですしにそうでう
どうでもよくない人がいるかもしれない
なので俺は今、この動画を
撮っている
コーヒー飲む人いますか
あのーあのー
僕は
飲みません
一時期気の迷いで飲んでた時期があったんですけど
僕はもう悟りを開いて
コーヒーは苦い、から美味しくない
という子供な発想に落ち着いてしまって、最近は飲んでないんですけど
動画見てる人もわかる人も多いと思うから（？）
ひょっとしたら、あのぉ～
「コーヒーなんて飲まねぇよ！」と思った人が多いと思うんですよ。
ひょっとしたら飲むことがあるかもしれない。今後
君たちが、年老いて！味の志向が変わって、今は、「やれ、メロンジュース、
オレンジジュース、コーラ、飲んでるかもしれないけど（キッズ目線）
コーヒーがおいしく感じる時が、くるかもしれない。
そんなときのために、今回動画を採っておるので
みなさん良かったら、見てください！
まあ俺には関係ないんですけど（ここ強調）
あのコーヒーって色々種類がありませんか？
例えばこれだったら、「やさしい甘みとコク」って書いてあるんですよ。
多分いわゆる「レギュラーコーヒー」ってやつです。多分普通のコーヒー
これが「こだわりの香り立つコーヒー」の「無糖」なんですけど
0キロカロリー！
てーとー（低糖）
糖類61%減
これが「低糖」なんですけど「カロリーオフ」と書いてあります
ちょっと微妙に違う
飲みかけでごめんww
「甘さ控えめ」カロリーオフって書いてあります
甘さ控えめww(?)
でこちらが「微糖」糖類75%減！
あのここで私は言いたいｷﾘｯ
コーヒーは種類が多すぎる！（爆
もぅもぅなんかぁ・・
いいやん（？）
糖分取りたくない人だったら無糖とればいいやん（当然）
カロリーオフやら微糖やら低糖やら多いんですよ、選ぶ種類が
何を基準で判断すればいいのか？何が違うのか？
僕ちょっとわかんないで（みんな分からん）
ネットで調べたら負けだと思うのでぇ
今から僕がのんで、イメージを皆さんに伝えて、みなさんにどのコーヒーがいいのかというのを伝えたい
種類が多いのでわからん（泣
（検証開始）
①レギュラー
ゴクゴク・・・
感想：ああ、
感想：甘いね
感想：糖分がちゃんと入っているのがわかるね。
感想：これはやっぱりレギュラーだから分かることなのかもしれない
②無糖
ゴクゴク・・・
感想：クソま・・・★
感想：苦っ！！
感想：一時期ぼくなんか気が狂っちゃって無糖コーヒーが好きだったんですけどｗ
また志向が変わっちゃいましたw
③低糖
ゴクゴク・・・
感想：・・・・・
感想：あぁ！
感想：あぁやっぱり無糖と比べると、きちんと砂糖感がありますね
感想：甘くて、また飲みやすいかなって・・・思いました
フフフ★（？）
④甘さ控えめ
クンクン・・・
ゴクゴク・・
ゴクゴク（2回目）
ゴクゴク（3回目)
感想：どうなんだろう・・・
感想：分かんないな。※感想になってない
⑤カロリーオフ（あれ、甘さ控えめの感想は・・・？）
ゴクゴク・・・
⑥微糖（⑤の感想は顔で表現）
感想：ああもう無糖を寸前（？）
感想：無糖でええやん
感想：本当に微々たる量の砂糖が入っているので
感想：ちょっと甘いぐらい
どれの方がどれより甘いのか、甘くないのか、というのが分かりづらいと思うので
僕が並べてみましょう！
（説明）
結果：ご覧の通り
ダレトク動画でした（その通り）
今回の動画でみなさん、どのコーヒーが甘いか、甘くないか分かったと思います。
中間がカオス（？）なことになっていたので整理させていただきました
というわけで、この動画でお勧めしたい飲み物は、
コーラでええやん★（何でやねん！）
♪コラコラコラコラコラコラコラコラ
♪コーーーーヒーの甘さ
♪比べてーーーーみたけれーどーー
♪結局ーーーーコーラをー飲んじゃあったーよーー
♪コラコラコラコラ！
♪意味無し！